b
so ladies are you ready to host the
oscars yeah we're going to crush this we
just have to do better than last year's
host that is the thing yes totally it is
a competition in that way remember last
year's host god they must have sucked i
bet they got cancelled trash oh wait
there wasn't a host last year oh or the
year before come on or the year before
oh
boom we're already winning we're nailing
it give it to me okay the oscars live
sunday march 27th hosted by regina hall
amy schumer and wanda sykes on abc
[Music]
do you understand english
absolutely
good lord
oh well
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
all right
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
good evening public programming for 2022
oscar week is made possible in part by
the ruderman family foundation which
promotes authentic representation in the
entertainment industry and full
inclusion of people with disabilities
throughout all sectors of society
and now
please welcome the co-chairs of the
international feature film award
executive committee rajendra roy and
susanna beer
good evening
buona sera
question
those are the five languages of the
films we are honoring tonight
this is a celebration of international
film welcome
[Applause]
first of all i lost my voice so
excuse
we are so thrilled to be back in person
at the wonderful samuel
goldwyn theater
two years ago the film industry took a
pause
movie theaters temporarily closed their
doors
and we waited for this moment to return
here with you
we truly feel the love in this room
tonight
not only for international feature
category
but for the community of filmmakers and
film lovers alike
i'm gonna leave it to raj because this
is
clearly painful for everyone um
if you want any insight on this
particular condition there is an epic
selfie going around
from the director's dinner last night
they had a lot of fun
the nominated international feature
films were voted on by hundreds of
academy members from all over the globe
this year they collectively committed
many hours of their time to view the 92
films that were submitted to represent
their respective countries
many of these dedicated members are here
with us tonight and we would like to
thank them for their commitment passion
and hard work please give a round of
applause to the executive and voting
committee committee members of the
international feature film category
please stand if you're here with us
thank you so much
shall i continue
the international filmmakers who who are
here with us tonight helped remind us
why we fall in love with the movies
even though the global pandemic kept us
distanced their movies connected us they
kept our community of film lovers intact
they introduced us to unique characters
and transported us to different
locations from a roman remote mountain
in bhutan to the bustling city of naples
from an animated vision of war-torn
afghanistan to a contemporary fable in
oslo
through the landscapes of hiroshima
let's take a look at the five films
nominated for best international feature
film
[Applause]
fish
wake up
from bhutan lunana a yak in the
classroom powwow shanghi doji director
fish
[Music]
global
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chat
yes
hmm
oh
hello
[Applause]
from denmark flee
jonas poer rasmussen director
[Applause]
to
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
like the only tripod
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
saber
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
um
it
good
[Applause]
from italy the hand of god paulo
sorrentino director
the end
hello
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
know
is
foreign
foreign
the
[Music]
be
from japan drive my car
rushka hamaguchi director
be
my
foreign
hey
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
from norway the worst person in the
world joachim chur director
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
um
it was good
[Music]
i was thinking
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
um
things
you're just mine
please please join us welcoming the five
directors
of the international feature
sorry
that that you got the line out it's good
um so
as i read your names
please come up to the stage and receive
the official certificate of nomination
on behalf of your country
and susana beer will present that to you
academy team
so first
for the very first time from bhutan
director lunana a yak in the classroom
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
from denmark
jonas ostensin director flee
[Applause]
from italy
paolo sorrentino director the hand of
god
[Applause]
from japan rusuki hamaguchi director i
drive my car
[Applause]
uh
and from norway
your country the worst person in the
world no he's not he made it
[Applause]
i think they want a group shot right
[Applause]
so you don't get to keep them
and you got to give them back and get
them back later and you'll get them back
and please sit down
so
you all spend so much of this year
trying to or talking about your films
so we thought it would be really
interesting
in the spirit of being colleagues that
each of you talked about one of the
other films
so
yes
so
maestro sorrentino we will begin with
you
would you mind saying a few words and
again just very briefly
one or two minutes
about your colleague director hama
gucci's film drive my car just some
thoughts you have about drive my car
it's just a very brief description
brief description of the movie or of the
director
i'm sure we would all love to hear
description of the director but in this
case it's the movie
[Music]
first of all i am not so good to talk
about movies not only in my movie but
also other movies so i will be very
very short
and
this guy is a nightmare for all the
directors that
who love to go to the
important festivals very important
awards and
i think that we will
in the future we will
it's important that we do movies when he
is not going to do more at the moment
you know what i mean yes so
it's important that before doing a movie
we call him and say what are you going
to do
because
he's a great director and he's a great
example of how to do
how to do a deep
movie and
what can i say
it's
[Music]
he has done a great movie but i don't
know what to say i have to say that
there is something
in common with all the movies all the
five movies i think that it's
more important than to talk about the
single movies
and
the the the my feeling is that all these
movies have a great humanity a great
deep about the human being
a great sensibility about what means to
be
to be kind to be smart to be
good people
and this is the reason why these movies
are very important in this precise
moment of our history this is what i
think
thank you what else
that's perfect
thank you i can go ahead
for many many save it save it we
want more but it's now your film's turn
joakim will you speak to hand of god
please
yes i would love to
i was very moved by this film paolo you
made a
what i would say is a prime example of
personal cinema
i feel your
storytelling abilities
your eye
your love for the people that you tell
us the story about
it's a story that moved me deeply
because it's about how
loss and grief
changes us
but also makes us grow it doesn't only
destroy us even though it can feel like
that sometimes it's a hopeful film
um
it's also about sort of a coming-of-age
story but it's also a coming of becoming
an artist story that i without knowing
you i mean i know you a little bit now
because we traveled
and it's been an honor because i've been
a fan of your cinema for such a long
time you're a great great great great
filmmaker but i also sense that this
film is uh
even more so than anything you've done a
step towards
biographical
brave personal story and i think
it's very it's very we should remember
you know like making movies it's a big
big machine there's a lot of people
involved it's very hard to be vulnerable
and to take chances and risks like
you've done in this film so you know i i
would love to have spoken about all of
your films but i'm also glad to be
allowed to talk about paulo's film and
yeah
thank you for your moving thank you
thank you
jonas will you tell us something about
lunana
yes
pablo
i had a very
profound experience when i watch your
film i saw it at a hotel here in
hollywood
which feels
very
far from where the film takes place
but i grew up
in rural denmark and even though bhutan
and denmark are not alike at all i think
supposedly
both places are very happy places
very happy countries
but denmark is extremely flat
and bhutan is not
but
but i i i grew up in the countryside and
to watch your film reminded me of the
importance of being able to look far
growing up in a place where you can
cfr and things doesn't happen
immediately
and
your film
is really a profound story about what
happiness is
and
and um
and
what makes you feel calm and in center
of yourself
and i feel that very much so
thank you for making that
[Applause]
maybe you can return either the favor or
however you read that
to jonas and talk to us about flea
um
you know in i've said this many times in
my in my interviews but in my culture
when we say tell me a story in english
of course we say tell me a story
but in our culture when we say tell me a
story we say
please untie a knot for me
stories are supposed to have this
liberating
uh freeing and untying purpose in life
and when i watched flee that's what i
felt i felt untied i feel
uh you know there was a higher purpose
in the story you were telling
and it was even more personal for me
because um i'm an avid traveler and i
always end up going to places you know
where you know there are
the usual tourists don't go because i'm
always hunting for stories
and i i've been to afghanistan and you
know i was able to
meet people just like the characters in
your movie
and i think what
a very
essential
point of your film is that it teaches us
empathy and i think that is such an uh
valuable quality
from my travels in afghanistan that's
what i realized you know all human
beings we have empathy we have the same
love the same kindness
but unfortunately because of
politics religion we have built up these
barriers to segregate as us and them and
your film went a long way in uh
reminding me of to value empathy and i
think that's what we need to celebrate
uh in the present so thank you so much
and finally director hamaguchi would you
say a few words about the worst person
in the world yeah
yeah
so i'm the worst person in the world
it's very good
[Laughter]
is
um so first i came across the title of
the film and i didn't know anything
about it before i watched the movie and
because of the title i was thinking oh
maybe this movie is going to be about
mass murder and perhaps there's this
woman in the poster who looks really
refreshed maybe it's after she had
killed many people and i was getting
preparing myself for watching a very
scary movie
uh but then once i saw it it wasn't like
that at all it was an incredibly
refreshing film um and you know the
title worst person in the world and
maybe perhaps this is reflecting her
feeling about herself but it really made
me feel that it's really
all of these could be choices that we
all make um i think the worst person in
the world could be all of us and so i
really felt that the story was
incredibly universal
sorry
and that scene we all watched together i
really feel that if we all were to make
a romantic film about two people falling
in love i feel like that scene is the
scene that people will talk about for
decades as a reference point
[Applause]
but it's of course not just that it's
really also about
knowing that to fall in love also means
to separate that there's death also
involved that time is limited and i
think for that i think it's an
incredibly universal story it's really
about life i think it's a masterpiece so
thank you for making this film
a part of part of what's so interesting
about this category is the fact that we
all see films
from such a different perspective
we all
seem to watch the same images
and then because of our cultural
references
we understand them very differently and
yet universally
and which is why we wanted all of you to
talk about the other films
i think we also want you to talk about
your own films
as well
so yeah no and and very much to your
point paulo there is a connective uh
tissue there between the films um and
that to my mind uh has to do with
personal journeys right at the center of
each of your film is a is a personal
journey in some cases it's
autobiographical it's it's taken from
your own story in some cases it's
adapted uh from other material or other
life experiences but i'm curious we're
curious
what the personal journey of bringing
this film into the world has been for
you
um either as it relates to your film or
just generally um we all know how much
work it is to to launch a film and to
get it in front of viewers
uh we're curious
talk to us about what this last year
plus has been for you what
you know what's been the craziest
experience or the most profound thing
you've learned
in
sharing this film with audiences and
paolo perhaps since you're the new guy
by a lot and everything was new in a way
for you on this journey you could start
off
talking about
well i think
craziest experience is finding myself
here
you know this is my first film and
you know
thank you
and when we had our first panel
discussion i looked across the stage at
four of them and i i was telling them
that you know you guys are the reason
why i became a filmmaker you know you
guys inspired me and i find it so
surreal that now i'm here what kind of
discussion am i supposed to have with
you guys
uh but um you know
i think
the journey of this film this small film
made on solar batteries in the world's
most remote classroom the fact that it's
now
reached here uh you know at the oscars
this really really is a celebration of
all the possibilities that is possible
you know when it comes to art creativity
and uh since you were talking about the
you know the committees here who voted i
want to thank you all for for this
wonderful you know special opportunity
because uh you know i feel like
the story of luna coming here
it gives hopes to millions of
storytellers out there you know uh from
who are struggling who
who don't believe in what they're doing
who don't have the support who come from
small poor countries like bhutan you
guys have really given them a sense of
hope that when they see luna's journey
they're like hey that could be us too
you know we can make it so
it's been very very surreal
how was it received in bhutan oh very
very well very well you know uh
bhutanese film industry is very very
different from uh
you know the rest of the world you know
we have like
two cinemas with a high school projector
you know we go and plug in our laptop
and then usually the director sits in
the boot because they're worried that
someone will steal the film from the
laptop
but
the the the film was very well received
and that that was something i wanted to
do because you know as as many of you
know this is bhutan's first oscar
submission in 23 years you know um
there aren't many films coming out uh
and i'm sure now this journey will
inspire a lot of
bhutanese storytellers to also you know
make films
paulo
the hand of god
is
very personal story and so
um in in many chapters and involving
many characters who you know so well and
now we feel we know so well and maybe we
claim them a bit
how has it been sharing these very
personal characters with the world
right it's interesting because
all my in all my career i had the dream
to do
comedies
and i never succeeded
and
but in this movie in the first part of
the movie the people laughed a lot so i
was very happy because
i thought okay at the end of the
screening the people will come to speak
with me about
what is the funny in the movie instead
up under the opposite the people come to
me to share with me the pain the grief
and
so
it's it's six seven months that i am
around and i know many many stories
about the grief and the pain of the
people
and
um and i am a little bit tired to to
hear too many tragedies
but even because uh
there is nothing to say to somebody that
has lived a tragedy a big pain a big
grief so you can just hear
and to try to hug
but the call would
prevent us to hug each other
so but it was a it was an
um
for me to see how the people react
always in the same way uh
wherever i showed the movie because of
the movies
at the end of the day is a simple movie
about
simple feelings
about
yes
about the fact that in the life we can
laugh and we can cry
and
it's not easy to
[Music]
figure out the reasons why once we laugh
and once we cry yeah
that's it
i mean
continuing with the theme of grief
director hamaguchi
clearly at the
center of drive my car there is um well
they're both characters both lead
characters are dealing with this maybe
you could talk about
your experience of bringing this into
the world and and if you've had any
similar experiences to paulo
my
um generally speaking when i'm making
movies i'm not necessarily thinking
about the theme um i i'm really thinking
about my characters and how they're
going to get over their issues and
problems
and it's really
only after the film is being shown that
i'm starting to and hearing from other
people that i learned that this film is
actually about loss and also
regeneration and so um it's really
through the audience's reactions that i
really realize
and i don't say this about just my own
film but i feel this about everybody's
films here today
is that in some way or another each
story is really about loss and also but
then how these characters keep on living
whether that's the loss of a hometown or
whether that's loss of somebody you love
and i think i'm realizing very much and
feeling very much that these kinds of
stories are resonating with many people
in the audience
[Music]
[Music]
and you know obviously for me as well i
think loss is something
difficult to face that there's a fear of
loss i think it's really difficult to
face in general and i think when we see
these things happen on film we're given
a little bit of distance and i think
we're given the chance to really reflect
upon what loss actually means to us what
loss means to ourselves and i think
these films make that possible
and it's really through seeing the
reactions of the audience
that i really see that these stories are
really connecting with many people's
hearts
i thought when i watched the movie and
that might be
yet again one of those cultural
differences
that
in spite of it being about loss
in each scene there's such an
undercurrent of sense of humor
there's like
always a kind of doubleness
is that me reading into it or was that
intentional
i'm really thankful that you say that
because um my film tends to be seen as
something humorless and rather uh
serious but i do feel that
this each character in the film has a
sort of distance and maybe that distance
creates a little bit of irony or at
least a distance to be able to see
oneself and so i think ultimately there
was a hope for me that you can also feel
a brighter side a brighter feeling
amongst everything
so joachim
i get the sense that every millennial in
the universe has latched on to your film
and said this is my story
i this you got me
do you feel that pressure
am i just like i mean i'm not a
millennial so it's hard and also how are
you going to do that next time
i've done it for 15 years
no i'm joking i haven't no but i i it's
always this thing i try to do something
very personal and i i don't analyze it
generationally so who are you in the
phone i'm uh i don't know i'm all of
them
that's this that's the truth that's the
truth you've got to become all of them
to write them
truthfully it sounds cheesy but i it's
it's my honest answer and i write with
eskiel folks my dear old friend who have
who sit here somewhere and we sit in a
room and we don't think that we're gonna
make something about millennials or this
or that i mean i try to look at
characters i try to be a good observer
of people i know situations i've been in
and i i try to avoid
just getting into my own biographical
stuff because that's not a very funny
story so i try to find ways of
identifying into the characters that we
talk about and you're absolutely right
it's been a joy though i don't feel any
pressure
you know i work in norway in a country
with five million people and suddenly i
can meet interesting people in
turkey or france or la that say oh i
identify what you're doing and that's a
great joy it's it's my dream it's this
is me
uh having grown up being that kid who
watched films from everywhere else
having to read subtitles even american
films were foreign language to me you
know i
so so i had to to engage with the
cinematic language and this feeling that
i'm allowed to be a part and play a part
in that experience of of sharing
different cinematic possibilities and
being seen for that means a lot you know
i come from a third generation filmmaker
my grandfather was a filmmaker he wasn't
seen so much with his wonderful films my
parents worked with movies you know and
now now so i know what it's worth i
don't take it for granted you know
so actually i don't know i don't feel
pressure i feel joy if people say that
they feel close to my stuff
it's wonderful
and jonas
i'm sorry
i was just going to say you know you had
the the incredible responsibility of
translating um this story uh of
you know this refugee experience and
and one a story that became so intensely
relevant um to our times um in the
process of making it and releasing it um
just yeah talk about the the
sense of responsibility perhaps that you
had in translating that story
but you know in the beginning i didn't
think that i was gonna do a refugee
story
to me it was really a story about my
friend
and this thing that he had carried
around for these years and a fundamental
curiosity
about the story and
when we started making the film he had
a growing kind of
feeling that he needed to share his
story to get his past and present to
connect so it was really you know from
the friendship that this grew
and then in the process of making the
film
you know my perspective changed
we started out in 2013. the first
conversations in my living room in
copenhagen was in 2013
and then
15 the refugee crisis hit in europe and
we had certain refugees and highways all
over europe and also in denmark and i
thought well maybe i can give these
people a human face
because often they were just described
by
being just refugees and because a main
story took place
25 30 years ago
and was told from the inside of a
friendship that i could give some
new ones and perspectives to these
people we saw on the streets
and then all the work of making the film
and here we are now
with what's going on in the world and
it's been really
schizophrenic to be a part of this
campaigning
at the same time as it feels like the
world is on fire at the same time as
afghanistan tumbles as what's with
what's going on in ukraine
so to be on this kind of stage at film
festivals
having cartels
has been
surreal
but also
you know it became
more meaningful to me
to really push for getting this film out
there
because
that's a growing number of refugees
around the world and and
to give
um them to give a min
history
to be out there so they have something
they can relate to a nuanced portrait of
the refugee experience
and give a bit of hope that you can
get past it and not be a refugee anymore
and become a full human being again
which really
has been
you know really what i'm taking from the
experience of getting to come out there
[Applause]
so we asked a little bit about the
impact um your film has had in in your
country powell but um
anybody else want to speak about the
impact locally um assuming they've your
films have all been released in your
your home countries
can i just ask sorry i just
so the impact i just wanted to
the impact globally
on flea
what have that been i mean what have it
i mean
in this part of the world yes but
have anybody in afghanistan seen have
you got
uh reactions from
from the source
um i haven't i don't know if there's
been any screenings in afghanistan i
think that's very difficult right now um
but i've had a lot of afghans who've
seen the film um
and who both people who lived in
afghanistan in the 80s when i lived
there and who recognized their own home
and people who
and not just people from afghanistan
people who have tried to be a refugee
who really feel
seen
by a mean story
that is not just his story but it's also
their story um
you know and
in in denmark locally uh
our premiere was at a very bad time it
was
first week of summer
uh our premiere day was the same day as
denmark played
belgium in the european football
championship
which meant that either people were on
the beach or they were watching football
what you call soccer here so
um so we didn't have a lot of audiences
in the beginning but slowly uh you know
with everything the film has done
globally uh
a large audience has been there even
though i just read that the prime
minister haven't seen it yet so
that's what i'm hoping for next that
she's going to see it and maybe make a
bit of change in the
legislation in denmark
i mean i can add to that being danish as
well
and that um
that it's it makes a huge difference
to a movie locally that it has a global
audience
you know movie can die and then
some it's they're being seen somewhere
else and then they get a completely
different life actually if i can add
something to that i think uh people here
in hollywood and the academy members you
all have a very important responsibility
because
you know what you decide kind of
influences the rest of the world
and you know even with my film
once it was shortlisted and
eventually nominated you know the rest
of the world that including bhutanese
themselves then started paying attention
to it so you know what you decide then
the rest of the world follows suit so
you know
we are very conscientious of that which
is why we are so
eager not for any small
wonderful
movie coming from
very far away not to be
left out or not to be forgotten because
they they tend to be you know they
obviously all the big territories know
how to
put a movie out there
so we are very conscious of that
and very grateful
because
for all of us it's a window into worlds
we don't get access to
otherwise
which is fascinating
paulo do you want to talk i mean you are
you're one of um your country's leading
artists at this point kind of with the
global
impact but again coming back to you know
you coming to tell a personal story what
has the reception been in italy to the
film
uh
now the reception was very good i have
to say better than other movies i did so
it was very very good
and
[Music]
and the movie was also released in italy
in cinemas for three weeks
uh of course i will not say the numbers
because i can't because of netflix but
now that the movie was a huge success in
italy yeah and i am happy
about that then um
yes
that's it no i mean actually that's an
interesting point and one we shouldn't
necessarily gloss over is that your
films were all released in a time when
streaming was incredibly important for
viewership right um
theatrical was coming back and forth and
so um director hamaguchi i don't know i
mean your film to me feels incredibly
theatrical meaning cinematic like that's
how i want to see it but
i would say i would guess the majority
of people have seen it on some sort of
platform
high
yes you know just having just seen these
clips in this theater really just
reconfirmed to me how wonderful of an
experience it is to watch films in a
theater and i think ultimately
[Applause]
i think ultimately it's because of the
concentration you're able to have as an
audience member to be able to watch the
film and i think concentration is
incredibly important for movie watching
foreign
but concentration could be a scary thing
at the same time because it means that
the audience can also notice anything
that perhaps i missed on set in a scene
for example the audience can see
different details they can see they can
witness a lie they can notice mistakes
and so when i'm making films i am really
thinking about about this and how to
respond to people's concentrations
but at the end of the day i think the
power of concentration can happen
anywhere whether it's streaming on or in
theater after all or in theaters because
after all when i really want to watch
something i'd still watch it on bad
resolution on youtube and i'll still
watch it so it's really not about good
or bad but it's really about um i am
thinking about how i can make a film
that won't be embarrassing to an
audience who is very much concentrated
on the film
joaquin you're nodding in agreement do
you i know i i love what he's saying
it's great no i agree i mean i still
shoot on 35.
my film has not you know been released
to be streamed anywhere yet it's still
out in the theaters it's still rolling
out uh we're actually proving in a lot
of countries that people want to go see
specialized cinema personal cinema
whatever you want to call it art house
cinema
in the theaters it's still alive it's
still powerful it's still strong you
know many films are proving that right
now and and there's a kind of um
i don't know i'm kind of i'm tempted to
coin the phrase deep viewing you know i
like that i like that you were engulfed
in a movie you put away your phone
you're there with other people you're
sharing that you can make you know
cinema's a great film
place to deal with films of loneliness
and i think a lot of these
movies are dealing with that solitude
but you're sharing it in a room like
this this is how i grew up loving movies
i also grew up in a part of the world
where the close-up was important it was
a humanist act if you look at dreyer
from denmark or bergman from sweden
close-ups is something uniquely
cinematic looking into the eyes of
someone who fills the screen in front of
you and you can go
and have a sense of intimacy closer than
you would in your social life almost and
experience the human experience that you
empathize with identify with observe
closely like kamaguchi so wonderfully
put it maybe there are even mistakes
that we make that they'll see and maybe
those mistakes can make the film better
sometimes
so i think the theatrical experience is
essential you know i i i love it i'm
gonna keep shooting for the big screen
it's what i'm into
um
yeah so i'm a film nerd forgive me
this is this is one of the largest
gatherings i think of the film nerd club
in quite a while so no i'm sensing it
good
so um before we we wrap up this amazing
gathering um
i just wanted to take no we wanted to
note that this is a historic group i
mean you're all making history in your
own ways
obviously with with your work out in the
world but also in the context of the
academy and and this year's oscars the
94th oscars
a few years back your colleague bong
joon ho who also made some history in
the academy
challenged um the world to
look past that one-inch barrier right to
get over that one-inch barrier and just
your thoughts on the progress that we
collectively as a film community have
made and the world has made in embracing
um i think kim you put it this way um
everything is foreign language depending
on where you're sitting but in the case
of a u.s audience perhaps looking beyond
that one-inch barrier and
optimistic
pessimistic where do you stand
can i it's it's the irony right because
paulus works with netflix and of course
we we all want netflix to buy a lot of
cinema chains and to show form some big
screen because they make so many good
movies
what netflix has done which is wonderful
is that i think they've helped a lot of
american
audience members accept films with
subtitles it seems to be happening you
know this is what i hear i'm not a
sociologist you know other people are
smarter than me but but i'm happy if
they're helping that process around the
world that we are sharing films
and tv shows between cultures you know
so i'm rooting for that part of it and
then i just hope they're going to buy
some cinema chains and get that
alternative out there can we co-exist
you know
i mean
there's no
there's no doubt that
that
international exchange have been greatly
helped by [ __ ]
i believe what she was trying to say
[ __ ]
by the streamers
there's no doubt about that
um
the one thing
being the only woman in this panel
that i find slightly regrettable
is that very fact
that we have such a rich
collection and yet we are still in so
many ways
there's still work to there's still
quite a bit of way to go
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and so you spoke about the 1-h barrier
and this idea of subtitles that could be
barriers or seen as barriers but to me
it's not a barrier in fact subtitles is
a bridge it's a bridge that connects
um i have been watching american films
as a child and that's always been with
subtitles and i never once felt that
they were barriers um and to me it was
really
the
it was really connecting and bringing
the world of films together and to me i
think it's also a wonderful way to also
be able to hear the voices of the actors
themselves
um and so i really feel that um
subtitles is because we are able to
actually hear the raw real voices of the
actors themselves i think it's a very
simple and easy way for all of us to
understand that even though we might
speak differently
look different we're still the same
people we're still humans and so i think
that is the power of subtitles and i
think the fact that film culture has
been able to build subtitle culture is
something that we can be proud of
[Applause]
paulo i don't know i don't know the
question about i i am not very
interested about the question of
subtitles the language i am only
interested into a very simple thing that
the movie must be beautiful
and in order to do a beautiful film the
filmmaker must be free
that's it for me
but you but you come you come from a
culture
where there's a lot of topping
a lot of dubbing
and um
um
i think for
i think in a way the point is that
that we
by
what the subtitle does
is that it you stay with the characters
and you stay with the soul of the film
and you remove a lot of them
so by dropping stuff
and
in a way if we could expand the love of
subtitles we would also expand the
the diversity
and the generosity
to a lot of different cultures
i think that was a point
yeah it is it is it is i agree i agree
no no no i was thinking uh i don't know
because for example stalin kubrick hated
the subtitles he thought that the best
thing was to dub the movies
and uh
he and and and and it was fine as well
so
many i think that
everything can work if a movie is
beautiful everything
it's very simple for me
if anybody has proven that point paolo
it's you it's true
you you have proven that point many
times
okay thank you
[Laughter]
uh jonas you had the triple threat of um
subtitles in a documentary that's also
animated um
and you've succeeded wildly in you know
literally making history at this year's
oscars with three nominations
but um
was that i know that there is plan there
might be plans or there were plans for
there to be an unsubtle version of this
for international markets
yes we have a french version and an
english dub version
um that's going to be out um soon maybe
it's even out now i actually not sure
um
but you know that was really from a
perspective that this story is so
important so if we can get it to a
broader audience in france and in
english-speaking countries
and i'm sure also you know spanish and
italian team networks are going to
double as well
but for us just to be able to keep
control over the dub uh
we we
engage with the resemet and you guys
who dubbed it so we have that but you
know i'm i love subtitles i i grew up in
denmark where everything is subtitled i
even put subtitles on danish things
because i don't want to miss things you
know it's
i um
i i
yeah so to me it's not a barrier it's
something that that should be there and
and
for us it was really just to make sure
that we could push this film as far out
as possible so we did dub versions but i
really hope people will see the original
version because there's so much
of the story in the voice
that's really you know in the call of
this film is a testimony from a real
person
and the story is in the voice so i
really hope people will see that and
then
maybe but if i can get people to see
that after they saw the dub version
that'd be great
absolutely
powell
last word to the new guy
you know i never uh
minded the subtitles in fact uh just
like jonas i watch english movies with
english subtitles to get all the message
uh through as well but i think the
situation is i mean getting better you
know i mean when i look at a
flea worst person in the world even
drive my car
the fact that foreign languages are now
being nominated for multiple
awards and on top of that even uh best
screenplay you know it shows that the
audience is getting past uh the
subtitles
but the other thing is the fact that the
front runner one of the front runners
you know coda is mostly with subtitles
and that's doing really great uh
commercially i think he just named a
front runner i don't know if that's news
or
that's not official academy
in a different category
[Laughter]
so it shows that
is you know getting past uh the
what did uh one inch what didn't you
barrier
gentlemen
madam
thank you
very much
so ridiculous we want to thank you so so
much for your work most of all for your
films for your presence and your
generosity with that
can we just add that
i know
i mean i'm not just i mean i've been
there you all want to win
i've tried both
and it's
of course more fun to win but
just being here is such a [ __ ] big
deal sorry my language
and
and and being in this amazing company
such a big deal so i think we should all
stand up and we should all absolutely
give
the nominees a hand
and watch the oscars on abc sunday
evening
thank you everyone thank you for joining
us thank you support international film
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you